what's up Gary so um you know I just
quit my job at radio after being on air
since I was 16 years old it kind of
risked everything for this new - radio
app I hope you've checked it out you
gotta tell me a favorite station but
what was the riskiest thing you've ever
done in your career because it was tough
for me to leave something I've been in
for so long especially an institution
like traditional radio in order to try
something new with zero listeners today
disrupt that industry what was the
toughest choice you ever made in your
life or in business about leaving
something that you've done to do
something there you know again the
enormous excitement I have behind doing
this show and thank you all for allowing
me to do this show is predicated on the
fact that I get to tell you things
you've never heard before I'm gonna say
something that I never ever ever ever
ever ever have talked about before which
is the toughest professional thing I've
ever done my cliche answer historically
has been you know leaving the Wine
Library which is my first love and
that's a very big truth but as I've
started becoming a little bit more in
tune with my own feelings and and have
given this thought the toughest thing I
ever had to do and Steve - even like
this answer the toughest thing I ever
had to do believe it or not was make the
decision that I was okay with putting
myself out there it you know a lot of
you probably have at this point
forgotten because the Gary Vee persona
and narrative has taken over my career
in my Wikipedian thinks of that nature
but the first 10 to 15 articles that
have ever been written about me in the
AP and the New York Times in The Wall
Street Journal was wizkid bills business
that the establishment the business
world the people that I look up to it in
ways maybe not specifically because I
don't really have heroes but like
respect their their opinions and and
their accomplishments I went from the
narrative of being a great business
operator that saw trends and executed it
for the financial gain which is like
something everybody deems to be so noble
in business to being a self-promoter to
being a social media guru to being an
author making the decision that I could
accept the rolling of the eyes of the
Ivy League grads or the establishment to
get bigger reach to build audience to
jam with people to be human than an
extroverted and taking that step back or
two or three in the minds of the top two
or three percent was a pretty
interesting difficult decision for me
knowing what the consequences were of
putting myself out there and that I
would be respected unless for my
business accomplishments because of it
wasn't the easiest thing that I ever had
to deal with in something that's very
honestly I still continue to deal with I
know this is where you start getting
into the I don't know do you want to get
the dog but this is when you start
getting into the darkness of it in a
weird way it's I like the
underestimation that comes along with it
as well because the truth is the reason
that entrepreneurship and business
speaks to me especially in an American
context is that the truth is undefeated
that ultimately you know if I go and
execute multiple hundred million dollar
businesses and make smart investments
it's all net net right like you may not
like the fact that I don't dress up or
that I curse onstage or that I self
promote or whatever you want to call it
but if I execute you just have to eat it
and so that was clearly DJ that was
clearly the toughest thing for me which
was that I was consciously self-aware
that I was entering a realm where I
would start becoming more disrespected
even though my accomplishments were
going to be greater that Mis positioning
was something that I was tough